all right let's start guys okay so a few
announcements before we start so if you
have if you need away.he accommodations
please let us know if you haven't done
that already so you need to let us know
by October 31st because we need to
figure out the alternate exam date so
we'll get back to you about the exact
like details around the alternate exam
date but let us know by October 31st
project proposals are also due this
Thursday so to talk to the TAS you talk
to us come to office hours alright so
today we want to talk about games so so
we have started talking about this idea
of state based models like the fact that
you want to have state as a way of
representing everything about everything
that we need to plan for the future we
talked about search problems already if
you have talked about MVPs where we have
a setting where we are playing against
the nature and and the nature can play
like probabilistically and then based on
that and we need to respond and today we
want to talk about games so so the setup
is we have two players playing against
each other so we're not necessarily
playing against nature which can act
probabilistically we're actually playing
against another intelligent agent that's
deciding for for his own or her own good
so so that's kind of the main idea of of
games alright so so let's start with an
example so this is actually an example
that you're gonna use throughout the
lecture all right so the example is we
have three buckets we have a B and C and
then you're choosing one of these three
buckets and then I choose a number from
the bucket and the question is well well
your goal here is to maximize the chosen
number and the question is which bucket
would you use okay so so how many of you
would choose bucket a no one trusts me
okay it's how much good how many of you
choose B okay so now if people don't
trust me how many of you to see okay so
so there's a number of people there yeah
so so how are you making that decision
so the way you are making this decision
is if you choose a you're basically
assuming that I'm not playing like like
trying I'm not trying to get you I might
actually give you 50 and if I
you fifty that'll be awesome and you
have this very large value that you're
trying to maximize if you think I'm
going to act adversarial and go against
you and try to minimize your your number
then you're going to choose bucket B
right because because worst case
scenario I'll choose the lowest number
of the bucket and and in buckets be the
lowest number is one which is better
than minus 50 and minus 5 so if you're
assuming I'm trying to like minimize
your good then you're gonna choose
bucket B and then if you have no idea
how I'm playing and you're just assuming
maybe I'm acting ad stochastically and
maybe I'm like flipping a coin and then
based on that deciding like what number
to give you you might choose C because
in expectation C is not bad right like
seems like if you just averaged out
these numbers and then pick the average
values from ABC a and B and see the
average value for a is 0 for B it's 2
and then for C is 5 right so so so if
I'm playing in stochastically you might
say oh I'm probably going to give you
something around 5 so you would pick C
okay so so today we want to talk about
these different policies that you might
choose in these settings and how we
should model our opponent and how we
formalize these problems at game
problems so this is an example that Dad
we just started ok so so the plan is to
formalize games talk about how we
compute values in the setting of games
so we're going to talk about expecting
Max and minimax and then towards the end
of the lecture we're gonna talk about
how to make things faster so we're gonna
talk about evaluation functions as a way
of making things faster which is using
domain knowledge to define evaluation
functions over notes we're also going to
talk about alpha beta pruning which is a
more general way of pruning your tree
and making things faster yeah all right
so that's the plan for today okay so we
just defined a scam and the way that to
go about this game is to create
something that's called a game tree a
game tree is very similar to a search
tree so this might remind you of search
tree where we talked about it like two
weeks ago
right so so the idea is we have this
game tree where we have notes in the
industry and each node is a decision
point of a player and we have different
players here right like I was flying or
you were playing you like we have two
different people like playing here so
these decision notes
could be for what one of the players not
both of them and then each roots to leaf
path is going to be a possible outcome
of the game okay so like it could be
that I'm choosing minus 50 and then your
decision was to pick bucket a so that
path is going to give us one possible
outcome of how things can go okay so so
that is what the tree is basically
representing here so the notes and in
the first level or the decisions that I
was making and in the the first node the
roots node are the decisions that you
were making in this setting so if you
were to formalize this a little bit more
we're gonna formalize this problem as a
two player zero-sum game okay so so in
this class at least like today we are
going to talk about two player games
where we have an agent and we have an
opponent and then we are going to talk
about policies and values and for all of
those things think of yourself as being
the agent so you're playing for the
agent you're optimizing for the agent
opponent is this opponent that's playing
against okay so we're also going to like
today we're going to talk about games
that are turn-taking games so we're
going to talk about things like chess
we're not talking about things like
rock-paper-scissors we will talk about
that actually next time then we have
like seeing like simultaneous games
where you're playing simultaneously
today we are talking about turn-taking
settings two-player turn-taking settings
full observability we see everything
we're not talking about like games like
poker where you don't necessarily see
like you have partial observation and
you don't necessarily see the hand of
your opponent full observation to player
and also zero-sum games and what
zero-sum means is if I'm winning and if
I'm getting like ten dollars from
winning then my opponent is losing ten
dollars so the total utility is going to
be equal to zero if I win some amount my
opponent is losing the same amount all
right so so what are the things that we
need when we define games so we need to
know the players we have the agent we
have the opponent in addition to that
you need to define a bunch of things
this should remind you of the search
lecture or them if you like sure so we
might have a start state that's a start
we have actions which is a function of
states which gives us the possible
actions from a state s similar to before
you have a successor functions
to search problems so successor function
takes a state an action and it tells us
what's the resulting state you're going
to end up and this and you have an is
end function which checks if you're in
an end state or not and the thing that's
different here there are two things that
are different here one is this utility
function and the utility function
basically gives us the agents utility at
the end State so one thing to notice
here is is that the utility only comes
at an end state so after you finish the
game like I've played my chest and I
have one chest now and this is this
chess game and and then I get my utility
like as I'm making moves like through my
chess game I'm not getting getting any
utility it's like you only get the
utility at an end state and I no way
they are defined me utility as you are
defining it for the agent because again
we are we're playing from perspective of
the agent so so what would be the
utility of the opponent - that right so
the negation of that would be the
utility of opponent I've heard about
partially observable Markov decision
process this like kind of what it is
okay so the question is is this
partially observable Markov decision
process this is not a partially
observable Markov decision processes
there are classes that talk about like
there's this decision under uncertainty
michael Koch endure first class that
actually teaches that so you should
shoot you should take classes on that
this is not partially observable Markov
decision process this is fully
observable you have two players playing
against each other so very different
setup so so the question is are there
any random this year and and so far I
haven't discussed any randomness yet
later in the lecture I'll talk actually
about the case where there might be a
nature in the middle that acts randomly
and then how we go about it but so far
two players playing against each other
okay all right and then the other thing
that we need to define when we are
defining a game is is the player so so a
player is a function of state and
basically tells us who is in control
like who is playing now so in the game
of chess the coos turn is it now and and
Ida is a function that we are going to
define when we are formally defining a
game okay all right so so let's look at
an example so we have a game of chess
players or white
and black let's say you're playing for
white so the agent is white the opponent
is black and then the state s can
represent the position of all pieces and
who started this so that is going to
what the state is representing so whose
players turn it is and the position of
all pieces so actions would be all the
legal chess moves that player s can take
and then is ends basically checks if the
state is checkmate or draw that is what
is so so then what would the utility be
the utility will be will be if you're
like you're only going to get it when
you win or when you lose or or if
there's a draw so the way we are
defining it is it's going to be let's
say plus infinity if white wins because
because the agent is white and and it's
going to be zero if there is a draw and
then it's going to be minus infinity if
black wins
yeah so so that was all the things that
we would need to define yes
why do we have why do we have whose turn
it is in this state and so that's one
way of actually like extracting the
player function so you defy you can
define the player function is a player
is a function of state so the state
already needs to encode whose turn it is
so you can kind of extract that this way
you said the killer but you probably
been negative utility for the the agent
is that assuming that both taking the
same actions no so so so this is
turn-taking right so I take an action
and then the opponent takes an action
and an agent a connection opponent takes
an action and then at the very end of
the game then then you get the utility
and then the opponent gets in to get
negative of that utility but the actions
could be very different policies could
be very different and we'll talk about
how to come up with that so why is the
condition like very influential exactly
for what wins you get plus infinity but
we just black when you trade but if
black plays black wins you have you
don't have a zero-sum game we'll talk
about that next lecture actually a
little bit so so I'm talking about
zero-sum games here because the
algorithms you're talking about are for
zero-sum games like we're going to talk
about minute minimax type policies where
I'm minimizing and the agent that's
maximizing so I'll get back to that if I
haven't understand sir that like we can
talk about it after the class but also
next lecture we'll talk about more
variations of games so but for now I'm
assuming a bunch of simplifying
assumptions about the assumption of
stuff like you're twins
why twins back at zero that's time yeah
so this utilities need to add up to zero
if white wins maybe white gets ten but
black gets minus ten
so so like any titles okay all right so
and then kind of the characteristics of
games that we have already discussed are
two main things one is that all
utilities are at end state so throughout
this path you're not getting in
utilities as opposed to like things like
MVPs or we were getting rewards like
throughout the path but here like the
utility only comes in at the very end at
the end state and then the other thing
about it is that different players are
in control at different states right
like if you're in state you might not be
able to control things in my control
things it might be your opponent's turn
I knew
be able to do anything okay so those are
kind of the two main characteristics of
games all right so let's look at a game
that you're going to play alright so the
game is a half a game so we start with
the number and and then the player and
the players take turn and they can do
two things they can either subtract one
second decrement N or they can replace n
with n over two so they can divide or
subtract yeah and the player that's left
with zero is going to win okay so that
is that is the setup is that so I'll
follow that so so let's try to formalize
the game and then after that you want to
figure out what is a good policy to do
it so so right now let's just try to
let's just try to formalize this say
like what are all the different things
for the model R so let's just have a new
file we are going to define this game so
it's 1/2 in game this alright so if
you're initializing with n so we're
starting with some number n so what is
our state where our state is going to
encode whose player turn it is and that
number n ok so we have a player let's
say our players are either plus 1 or
minus 1 that's how I'm defining like
whose player this so the start state
let's say player plus 1 place with n so
so that is plus 1 and N and then we need
to define is and ok so what should is n
check well we take the state we decouple
it into player and number and if the
number is equal to 0 then then that is
when the game ends that's our ending
condition ok
how about utility well we get the
utility at an end state so again I take
a state I decouple it into player and
number I make sure that we are in an end
state so we search that number is equal
to 0 because that kind of defines if
you're in an end state or not and then
the utility I'm gonna get if I'm winning
I'm gonna get infinity if I'm not
winning I'm gonna get minus infinity and
the way I'm defining that here is by
just doing player times infinity because
player I'm the agent I'm the player plus
1 the opponent is player
a swan that's how like if -1 is winning
I'm gonna get minus infinity okay the
actions that we can do is we can
subtract 1 or we can divide
/ - I mean subtract and avoid or the
main actions and play your display or
function again takes a state I'm going
to decouple this state into player a
number and just return the player that's
how I know whose player's turn is and
then we need to define the successor
function the successor function takes
the state and an action and tells us
what state you're gonna end up by so
again a state I'm going to decouple that
into a player and a number and then the
actions I can take are two things I can
either subtract 1 or I can I can divide
by 2 so if I'm subtracting then I'm
going to return a new state which is -
player because now it's - once turn or
+1 so like it's - whoever turned to this
now and then I'm going to do number
minus 1 if the action is divided we are
going to return the new player which is
- player and then number / - okay that
is it
so so we just defined this game
all right so so that was my game we were
gonna play this game in a little bit but
let's quickly before playing it let's
talk about what is a solution to a game
like what are we trying to do in a game
so if you remember MVPs the solution to
a game was with a policy so a policy was
a function of state it would return the
action that you need to take in that
state so similar term the piece here we
have policies but but the thing is I
have two players so policy should depend
on the player two so I have pi of P
which is the policy of player P and I
can define it similar to before it can
be a policy as a function of a state and
it can return just an action and this
would be a deterministic policy like
deterministically if I'm in a state the
policy is going to tell me what action
to take yes we can also define
stochastic policies so what's the
catholic policies would do is they would
take a state and action and then they
would return a number between 0 to 1
which is the probability of taking that
action so policy PI of a state and
action basically will return the
probability of player P taking action a
in state s so if you remember the bucket
example like maybe half the time I would
pick the number on the right and half
the time I would pick the number under
on the left that would be a stochastic
policy right I'm not deterministically
telling you what the action is I'm
coming up with the stochastic way of
telling you like what policy I'm falling
ok so if you have deterministic policies
stochastic policies like in our game we
could fall either one of them fantastic
policy as the student has been pausing
and can you speak up so under what case
would you want to stochastic policy
versus a deterministic policy so I know
what case do you want a stochastic
policy is a policy again we'll have
covered that a little bit more next time
depending on what games you are in like
we have some property yourself when
stochastic policies are giving us some
some properties than the term mystic
policies are giving us some other
properties right now you're just
defining them as things that could exist
and we could think our opponent is
acting deterministically if we know
exactly what they're doing sometimes
have no idea maybe you're like I've
learned it somehow and I have some
randomness there and then I'm gonna do
some stochastic policy for how my
opponent is going to play against me but
we are going to talk about the like what
we get out of a stochastic versus
deterministic policies a little bit more
next time yes all right so okay so now
let's okay so now that we know that it's
the policy that we want to get let's try
to let's try to write up a policy for
this game and then I'm gonna define a
human policy and what I mean by that is
this is going to come from a human that
means one of you guys or two of you guys
so um so I need two volunteers for this
but let's quickly actually write this up
so what is a human policy it's just
going to get the input from the keyboard
so what I'm going to tell you up here is
is get the action from from from the
keyboard so get the input from the
keyboard and that is going to be the
action that we are picking remember the
actions are either divide or subtract
subtract one and if action is valid then
return that action that sounds like a
good good policy okay so that is a human
policy so now what I want to do is I
want to have like this game that's
actually playing against each other so I
want to have policies for my agent my
agent is plus one that's going to be a
human policy and for my opponent I'm
gonna say my opponent is also a human
policy so I just want to humans to play
against each other and the game is let's
say we are starting with 15 so our
number that you're starting with is 15
okay all right
so that looks right to me
so how do we how do we ensure that we
are progressing in the game so if you're
in an NSA if you're not in an end-state
you want to progress
so let's print a bunch of things here
just print our state okay let's get the
player out of the state because again
the state encodes the player let's get
the policy because because we've defined
these policies for both of the players
so we can we can get the policy for
whoever is playing right now and then
the action comes from the policy in that
state and then the new state you are
gonna end up at is just a successor of
the current state and action so that I'm
just progressing so so this while loop
here just figures out what stage we are
in what policy are we following and
where are we going to end up at and
that's the successor function and
another very end I'm just going to print
out the utility so that's either plus
infinity or minus infinity and that
sounds good so all right so let's
actually alright so who wants play this
okay that's one person your agent your
player plus one opponent all three to
four I think you reversed white shirt
yeah okay so you're minus one all right
so let's play this yeah is this large
enough yeah okay all right so player 1
player +1 we are at number 15 you want
to decrement okay so minus 1 so you are
player minus 1 we are at 14 what do you
want to do divide okay you have a policy
that you know minus 1
oh yeah so I kind of get the point right
so wait do they make you lose now sorry
my back but when you get the utility at
the end and then basically kind of
actually does any no I don't know we
don't have down motion I was gonna try
like another pair but the code is online
if you wanna play with it just play with
it you'll have one other version playing
with an automated policy later
all right so okay so we're back here all
right so we just saw how we can give
some human policies and the human
policies playing against each other and
again the policy you give it a state an
action it gives you a probability or you
give it a state and it gives you an
action so the term Mystic policy is just
an instance of a stochastic policy right
so so if you have deterministic policy
you can kind of treat it as a stochastic
policy where with probability one you're
picking you're picking an action so
alright so so now we want to talk about
how we evaluate a game so so let's say
that someone comes in and gives me the
policy of an agent and an opponent and I
just want to know how good that was and
again if you remember the MVP lecture we
started with policy evaluation so
indemnity lecture we started with this
idea of someone gives me the policy if
you just want to evaluate how good that
is and you're kind of doing an analogous
to exactly that someone comes in and
tells me that my agent is going to
pickpocket eighth that is what my agent
is going to just do all the time and
someone comes in and says well my
opponent is going to access classically
and and with probability 1/2 you give me
one of those numbers ok so so these are
the two policies that we were going to
have so the question is how good is this
so going back to the to the tree the
game tree what is really happening is my
agent is going to pick this one right
because it's going to pickpocket
a so with probability 1 we are going to
end up here with probability 0 we end up
in any of these other buckets and then
my opponent is going to stochastically
pick either minus 50 or 50 ok
so if my opponent is picking minus 50 or
50 then the value of
snowed is just the the expectation of
that or it's just going to be zero so
50% of the times it's minus 50 or 50
percent of the times it's 50 then the
value of the snow Dussehra and then if
my agent is picking picking a then then
the value of this node is going to be
zero okay so so you kind of can see how
the value is going to propagate up from
the utility so we have the utilities are
the leaf nodes but we could actually
compute a value for each one of these
notes if I know what the policies are
right like if I know who is following
what policy I can actually compute these
values and go up the tree so in this
case I can say a value of the start
state if I'm evaluating this particular
policy is going to be equal to zero okay
all right so someone gave me the policy
I evaluated the value of the start State
so in general I guess I was just saying
earlier this is this is similar to two
policy evaluation this is similar to the
case that someone gives me the policies
and all evaluate what how good the
situation is and you can write a
recurrence to actually compute that so
I'm going to write the recurrence here
maybe so you want to compute this value
and this value is evaluating a given
policy it's a function of state but what
is that going to be equal to
it's going to be a quarter utility of s
if you're in an end state so it's
utility of s if we are already in an end
state otherwise I have access to the
policy of my opponent and policy of my
agent so I can just do and expect that
sum over all possible actions of us
let's say that I'm if player s is agent
I'm looking at policy of agent say it's
a stochastic policy times V of eval of
the successor state successor of SN a
and this is if my player is agent so so
if is player I'm just gonna write this
player of s is equal to agent
what happens if my players opponent I'm
gonna do the same thing I'm just
evaluating I have access to the policy
of the opponent I am again just doing
going to do a sum over all possible
actions of a policy of the opponent this
is given to me someone gave this to me
of state and action x value of the
successor state there's an a and this is
the case that my player is the opponent
here so this is the recurrence that we
were going to just write and it's kind
of intuitive again we have seen this
entry search shoe like you start with
the utilities at the leaf nodes and you
just push that back up based on what
your policies are and what your policies
are telling you like which sides like
which and which edges of the tree you
are taking what probably okay
this make sense all right okay so that
was evaluating the game but what if now
I want to solve what the agent should do
right like I am the agent I care about
doing like look like figuring out what
my PI agent is I don't know what my PI
agent is I need to figure out what sort
of policy I should be following and that
kind of takes us to this idea of expect
Emacs which is basically the idea of if
I'm in a scenario where I know what my
opponent does so I'm is still assuming
what I know what my opponent does what
would be the best thing that I should be
doing as an agent okay what would be the
best thing I should do like if you knew
like in the bucket example I was trying
I was acting probabilistic Lee what
would you do
the action that like gives you the
maximum so you pick the action that
gives you the maximum value because
you're trying to maximize your own your
own value so so then if that is the case
then this recurrence needs to change
right this recurrence the way it changes
is I'm gonna call this is that new value
so I'm gonna just do everything on top
of this I'm not rewriting it I'm gonna
call this value value of expecting max
policy okay so so this value eval I'm
not evaluating anything anymore I want
to actually figure out what my agent
should do so I'm gonna call it expect a
max and if I know a policy of my
opponent I'm not changing anything here
because I know the policy of my opponent
I'm just gonna compute this but now I
want to figure out what the agent should
do and what should the agent do mall the
agent should do the thing that maximizes
this value so I'm gonna erase this sum
with the policy because I don't have
that policy and the agent should do the
thing that maximizes this value so this
should remind you of value iteration so
if you remember value iteration in the
MVP lecture if you weren't evaluating
things right you were trying to maximize
our value and that's kind of like
analogous to what we are doing here
you're trying to figure out what should
be the policy that the agent should take
that maximizes the value under the
scenario that I know what the opponent
does so I still kind of know what the
opponent does so going back to this
example so let's say I know my opponent
is acting stochastically what should I
do
so if my opponent is acting
stochastically with probability 1/2 then
the values of each one of these buckets
are going to be 0 2 and 5 and I'm trying
to maximize my own you to my own value
so I'm gonna pick the one that gives me
5 and then that's shown with this upward
triangle I'm trying to maximize so I'm
gonna pick buckets see because I'm
trying to maximize under this knowledge
that the other agent is stochastic
reacting and and then we're calling this
the value of expecting max policy and
the value of expecting max policy from
the start state is equal to 5 right
because that's that's
you did I think I'm gonna get posture -
yes this is assuming I know my opponents
policy and then I'm following you Nick I
guess so I'm maximizing my own
you took my own value knowing that my
opponent is following this policy and
what the opponent would do an
expectation alright so and then this is
the this is the recurrence that you
would get we would just update the
recurrence so if the agent is playing
then we maximize the value of expecting
max okay all right so okay in general I
don't know the policy of my opponent
right so in general like I know what
gives me this payoff so so if that is
the case then what should we do so one
thing that we could do is we could
assume worst case so one thing that you
could do is it could be like oh the
opponent is trying to get me in and
they're going to play the worst-case
scenario and they are trying to minimize
my value and and that's the first thing
to do and we are going to talk about if
that is always the best thing we can do
or not a little bit later in the lecture
but for now like we could assume that if
I know nothing about my opponent I can
just assume my opponent is acting
adversarially against me so and that
kind of introduces this idea of minimax
as opposed to expect you know just
talking about so so what would minimax
so in the case of a minimax policy what
I am assuming is I am this agent trying
to maximize my my own my own value and
then I'm assuming my opponent is acting
adversarial so my opponent is really
trying to minimize my values and then
what that means is from this pocket I'm
gonna get minus 50 from this one I'm
gonna get one from this one I'm gonna
get minus five and under that assumption
well I'm gonna pick the second bucket
because that gives me the highest the
highest value so so that is a minimax
policy so how would I change my
recurrence if I were to play minimax oh
I'm gonna I'm going to call it vo let's
look at the V of minimax of a state well
the recurrence is going to be over our
minimax that we of minimax so let me
change that
if the agent is playing the agent is
still trying to maximize the value so
that is all good what if the opponent is
playing hmm the opponent is going to
minimize right so I don't have access to
PI up so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
remove this and say well the opponent is
going to take an action that minimizes
the value of the successor of SN a and
this is how you would compute the value
of minimax policy so what happens like
if the adversary or agent is not always
adversarial right so in that case you
have another stochastic policy that kind
of defines what the what the opponent is
doing and if you have access to then you
can do something similar to expect the
max if you don't have access to that
maybe you would want to like act
worse-case and assume that they're
always trying to minimize but but that's
some prior knowledge that you have that
allows you to track better or maybe
evaluate the value better for every
state so we will talk about evaluation
functions a little bit in the lecture
and maybe you look that can inform your
evaluation function all right so so so
here the value of minimax from the start
state is going to be one right does
everyone see that so I'm assuming my
opponent is acting adversarially so we
have minus 51 and minus 5 if I am
maximizing then the best thing I can get
is 1 and that's how we compute V of
minimax and then there is really no
analogy to this in MVP setting because
in the MVP setting you don't really have
this game we don't really have this
opponent that's playing against us and
what happens is is that this is the
recurrence that you're gonna get which
is what we already have on the board
right okay so so what would the policy
be so the policy is just going to be the
Arg max of this V of minimax so if you
want to know what the policy of your
agent should be that's PI max it's the
Arg max of V
minimax / successor of that state and if
you want to know what the policy of your
opponent that state s should be well
that's argument of me of minimax which
is intuitive it's other than that way
you can actually figure out what the
action should be what the policy what
the actual action should be okay all
right so let's go back to this example
this half in game so what we want to do
is you want to actually code up what a
minimax policy would do in this setting
and maybe we can play with a minimax
policy after that okay so what would a
minimax policy dudes so it's a policy so
it's going to be a function of states
it's just give it the state and you're
gonna just write this recursion that we
have on the board so so we're recursing
over the state if you're in an end state
then what are we returning just so
utility okay
so we're returning the utility of that
state and there's no actions and then if
you're not in an end state then you're
either maximizing or minimizing over a
set of choices so let's actually like
create those choices so they can just
call Max and min on them so the choices
we're going to iterate over all actions
that we have and and what is that going
to be exactly well that's going to be
doing a recursion over the successor
state so we're going to recurse over the
successor state so recurs over signal
game that successor of state in action
and I'm gonna return the action here too
because I just want to get the policy
later and the successor this district
URIs function returns a state in action
so I just want to get the state from the
first one in the action for the second
one okay so if player is plus 1 that's
the agent the agent should maximize the
choices and if player is minus 1 then
then that's the opponent the opponent
should try to minimize over these
choices and that's pretty much like this
recursion that we have on the board and
that's our recursive function
okay so we're gonna recurse over over
our state and that gives us a value and
it also gives us gives us an action so
let's just print things out so you can
refer to them so minimax gives us an
action and it tells us this is the value
that you can get all right and then it's
a policy so let's just return the action
okay so now what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna say +1 agent is still a human
policy and then it's playing against a
minimax policy so alright so let's who
wants to play with this it's a little
scarier to play with a mini policy
alright so let's do this
Python alright so you are the agent so
your player one you're starting from 15
what do you want to do so you just lost
the game why do I know you lost the game
oh now it's player minus one point we
are at 7 and minimax policy took action
minor and says action - and and and it
also yeah
takes action - so we're at 6 and then
the value of the game is minus infinity
so you're playing at a minimize policy
you're already getting minus infinity so
so you just lost you anyone want to try
this again you want to try it again
subtract okay so you can win right so
value is infinity right now and then
yeah so and then the minimax policy also
did a minus so we are at 13 right now
it's your turn you're at 13 you just
lost the game again yeah so minus
infinity yes yeah actually you need to
like alternate between them I think that
is the best policy but maybe this get a
sense of how this runs the code is on
line so just feel free to play with her
then figure out what is the best policy
to use all right
so okay so that was the minimax policy
and then this is kind of a recurrence
that we get for a minimax policy now
what I want to do is I want to spend a
little bit of time talking about some
properties of this minimax policy and
we've talked about two types of policies
so far right we've talked about
expecting max which is basically saying
I as an agent I'm trying to maximize but
I know what my opponent is going to do
so I'm going to assume my opponent does
whatever and then I'm going to maximize
based on that so so for example I am
following and I'm gonna refer that to a
spy of expecting max which means that
the agent and everything in red is for
the agent everything in blue is for the
opponent so I'm gonna say the agent is
following this policy which says I'm
going to maximize assuming my opponent
is doing whatever and here I'm calling
pi7
as like some opponent policy it could be
like anything but pi7
so let's say that's opponent is playing
PI 7 I am going to maximize based on
that and and the value we just talked
about is the value of expecting max the
other value we just talked about is the
value of minimax which says I am the
agent I am going to maximize assuming
the opponent is going to minimize and
then the opponent actually is going to
minimize and it's going to follow-up I
mean okay so so these are the two values
you have talked about so far I want to
talk a little bit about the properties
of this but before that let me sorry oh
wait it like kind of like mix the two
together we just say like
heightened like the probability of
typing the minimum for like in expectrum
acts I've double probability
distribution over like the actions right
so they're like why don't we just take
the action that like minimizes whatever
our reward is and give it a higher
weight I didn't fully follow is it are
you coming up with a new policy that
your thing would be a better policy
between like expecting Max and minimax
in something so this this this table
might kind of address that because it's
it's considering four different cases
it's actually not considering the two
cases so this might actually refer to
what you were what you were proposing so
so let's actually go through this first
and then maybe like if it doesn't answer
that so all right so so I want to talk
about a setting so this table it's
actually not that confusing but it can
get confusing so do pay attention to
this part all right so do I want to
maybe maybe I'll write it over there so
I'm gonna use red for agent blue one for
left my right okay all right okay and
then I'm gonna use before I'm gonna use
blue for the opponent policy okay so so
then for agent who are going to have pie
max right in agent could play pie max
what does that mean again I'm going to
maximize assuming you're going to
minimize an agent could play pie
expecting max maybe a policy 7 I'm going
to put 7 here which means I'm going to
maximize assuming you're going to follow
this pie 7 so this is a thing that the
agents can do okay and then there are
things that my opponent can you I'm
gonna write that here my opponent can
actually follow pie min which is I'm
just going to minimize all my opponent
could follow some other policy PI 7
let's say PI 7 in the bucket example
right now is just acting as
stochastically so half the time pick one
number half the time pick another number
okay so so that is
what we have so I'm gonna draw my
actually my tree so we can go over
examples of that too so this was the
bucket example we started at minus 50
and 50 in bucket a 1 and 3 in bucket B
minus 5 and 15 in bucket C ok so this
was my buckets example I'm actually
going to talk about it so alright so I'm
going to talk about a bunch of
properties of me of Pi Max and timing
which is what we have been referring to
as the minimax value okay so I want to
talk about this a little bit so the
first property that that we can have is
is that V of Pi max time in is it is
going to be an upper bound of any other
value of any other policy pi of I'm
gonna just write PI of expecting max for
any other policy for the agent assuming
that my opponent is playing as a
minimizer okay so so what I'm writing so
what I'm writing here is is the value is
going to be an upper bound of any other
value if my agent decides to do anything
else under the assumption that my
opponent is a minimizer so my opponent
is really trying to get me if my
opponent is really trying to get me then
the best thing I can do is to maximize
okay so that's kind of intuitive right
that's an upper bound let's look at that
example so what is PI V of Pi mix PI max
and PI min so so we just talked about
that right so if this guy is a minimizer
we're gonna get minus 50 here 1 here
minus 5 here if this guy is a Maximizer
what is the value I'm gonna get get it 1
right I'm gonna go down here and then
I'm gonna get one so V of PI max and
timing is just equal to 1 that is this
value that is just equal to 1 okay what
is this saying is that this is going to
be greater than
maybe the setting where my opponent
sorry my my agent is following expecting
max and my opponent is still doing
timing so so what would this correspond
to what would this value correspond to
so this is a value which says well I'm
going to take an action assuming my
opponent is acting as stochastically if
my opponent is acting stochastically I'm
gonna get zero here I'm gonna get two
here I'm gonna get five here if I'm
assuming that and I'm trying to maximize
my own my own value which trout do I go
I'm gonna go at this trout but it turns
out that my opponent was not doing that
my opponent was actually a minimizer so
if my opponent was actually a minimizer
and I went this route my opponent is
going to give me minus 5 so the value
I'm gonna end up getting is minus 5 so
this is equal to minus 5 this is equal
to minus y so so far I've shown that
this guy is greater than this guy all
right so that's the first property first
property is if my opponent is terrible
and is trying to get me best thing I can
do is to maximize I shouldn't do
anything else okay the second property
is is that this is V of Pi knocks again
the same be V of Pi Max and pi min is
now a lower bound of a setting where
your agent is maximizing assuming your
opponent is minimizing but your opponent
was actually not minimizing your
opponent was falling by 7 so so what
this says is if you're trying to
maximize assuming your agent or your
opponent is always minimizing then then
you're doing like you'll come up with
like a lower bound and if your opponent
ends up doing something else you can
always just do better than this lower
bound okay so what is what is this V you
call - well we just showed that is Titus
1 right that is this value okay what
does this correspond to so this is value
of pi max which is I am going to assume
you're trying to get me if I'm going to
assume you're trying to get me I'm going
to
on this route because that is the thing
that gives me the highest the highest
value but you're not trying to get me or
falling pi7
so if you're falling falling by seven
you're just going to give me half the
time one half the times three and that
actually corresponds to two and I'm
going to get value two instead of value
one so this is actually equal to two in
this case and this corresponds to this
value in the table which is again the
agent is following a Maximizer assuming
the opponent is a minimizer ponen was
not a minimize their opponent was just
following pi seven and this is just
equal to two okay so so far the things
I've shown are actually very intuitive
they seem a little complicated but
they're very intuitive what I've shown
is that this value of minimax it's an
upper bound if you're assuming our
opponent is a terrible opponent like
it's going to be an upper bound because
the best thing I can do is maximize I've
also shown it's a lower bound if my
opponent is not as bad so so that's
that's what I've shown so far secure the
opponent's policy is completely innocent
yeah so here like because yeah the agent
actually doesn't see the opponent where
the opponent does right even in the
expecting max case it thinks the
opponent is going to follow PI seven but
maybe the opponent falls at PI 7 maybe
not right so so like when we talk about
expecting Max and minimax it's always
the case that the opponent doesn't
actually see what the opponent does but
the opponent can't think like the agent
can think what the opponent does and I'm
going to talk about one more property
and this last property basically says if
you know something actually goes back to
your question if you know something
about your opponent right if you know
something about your opponent then you
shouldn't do that minimax policy you
should actually do the thing that has
some knowledge of what your opponent to
us so so that basically says this we PI
max and some PI of opponent
you know something about PI opponent you
know that opponent is playing PI 7 that
is going to be less than or equal to the
case where you are following the PI of
expect emacs of seven and the opponent
actually falls by seven okay so what is
this last equality inequality saying
well it is saying that the case where
you're trying to maximize and you think
your opponent is minimizing but your
opponent is actually not minimizing the
value of that is going to be less than a
case where you're maximizing under some
knowledge of your opponent's policy and
your opponent's policy actually ended up
doing that okay so so the first term is
always the agent the second term is
always the opponent right so so this
value we have already computed that
that's equal to 2 this value what is
this value saying it is saying you are
going to maximize assuming your opponent
is stochastic so if I'm assuming my
opponent is stochastic then I'm assuming
that this is 0 this is 2 this is 5 right
I am trying to maximize so which one am
I every track should I go I should go
this route because that gives me 5 so
this is the agent thinking the opponent
is going to be a stochastic thinking is
going to get 5 and it gets here and the
opponent actually ends up following PI 7
which is a stochastic thing so so we are
actually going to get 5 so so this guy
is equal to 5 and this is the last
inequality that we have
we are PI expecting a max of 7 and pi of
7 is greater than or equal to V of Pi
max and PI 7 we just showed this is
equal to 5
for this example ok all right
the reactions of your points always
whether or not if it's the guests is it
we say too so if you know something
about this the cast to say that's not
really like here I knew that the
opponent was following this is a casting
policy of one half one out I might have
known that the opponent is following a
deterministic policy and always is
picking the left one so I could have
like follows like a same expecting max
policy under that knowledge it could be
anything else but the whole idea of
expecting max is I have some knowledge
of what the policy of the opponent is it
could be a stochastic policy it could be
a deterministic policy under that how
would I maximize that me not like that
bottom right is greater than the bottom
always yeah so the question is do we
have so we have what is in equality so
transitively this guy is always greater
than this guy and that kind of makes
sense right like you're saying like if
you're following expecting max okay so
this last one kind of makes sense right
it's basically saying if you're
following expecting max and you know
something about your opponent and your
opponent actually ended up doing that so
though your value should be greater than
pretty much anything right because you
knew something about the opponent you
play knowing that having that knowledge
yes
is that just caste clear know what so
it's knowing what they're gonna take
right click here I knew what the point I
knew that half the time they're going to
take this one half the time you're going
to take the other one and then I use
that knowledge right now is the
expecting max policy given that your
opponent is following atomizer policy
given that given if your opponent is
following pipe in it is it to do a
Maximizer
so the expecting that policy is as this
policy when here we have a some the
expecting max policy assumes your
opponent is following PI opponent and
assumes that it has access to PI
opponent so it ends up doing this some
over here
we probably were saying so you're saying
if PI opponent is actually PI min then
do they end up being equal to each other
and yeah I guess yeah so you know that
you're poor it's becomes minimax right
if you know your opponent is following
me as I can't minimize every just like
all that minimax all right so I'm gonna
move ahead a little bit
all right so and then this is like what
we have already talked about okay
so a few other things about modifying
this game so so we have okay so we have
talked about this game we have talked
about properties of this game there's a
simple modification one can do which is
bring nature in so there was a question
earlier which was like is there any
chance here and then yeah you can like
actually bring chance inside here so so
let's say that you have the same game as
before you're choosing one of the three
bins and then after choosing one of the
three wins you can flip a coin and if
heads comes then you can move one bin to
the left with wraparound so what this
means is 50% of the time tails comes
you're not changing anything you have
this setup 50% of the time you get heads
and then in those settings you're just
gonna pick like a neighboring bin as
opposed to your zombie so so there
you're adding this notion of chance here
and and it's kind of acting as a new
player so so it's not actually the
making things that much more complicated
so so what happens is in some sense we
have a policy of a coin which is nature
here right and policy of coin is half
the time I get 0 I don't change anything
half the time I just get the neighboring
bin as opposed to my main bin and then I
get this new tree Berber I have like a
whole new level for what we're the
chance place so we have now we have max
nodes we have min nodes we also have
these chance nodes here and the chance
nodes again like sometimes they take me
to the original bucket and then 50% of
times they take me to a neighboring
bucket but but the whole story like
stays the same like nothing changes you
can you can still compute value
functions you can still push the value
functions further up it's the same sort
of recurrence nothing fundamental
changes just it just feels like there
are three things playing now so so then
this is actually called expecting
minimax so value of expecting minimax
here in this case for example is minus
two because there is a min node for the
opponent there's an expectation node for
what nature does and then there is a max
node for what the agent should do that's
why it's called expecting minimax and
then you can actually compute the same
value there's like two players I pick up
in then you flip the point and then
shift it left or notch it to left and
then I get to take the number yes well
you thought you loved the opponent yeah
yeah so there's still two players and
then the third coin think yes all right
so so yes so the way to formalize this
is you have players so you have an agent
you have an opponent down you have coin
and then the recurrence changes a little
bit I guess so so what happens is the
recurrence that we have had for minimax
was just the Max and min and it would
just return us the utility if you're in
an nth function and in an end-state now
if the if it is the coins term we just
do a sum over and expected some of their
policy of the coin which is what we were
doing expecting minimax but we just have
like a new return for one coin place so
so everything here kind of follows
naturally terms up what we're expecting
okay all right so the summary so far is
well we've been talking about max notes
we've been talking about chance notes
like what if you have a coin there and
then also these mid notes and and
basically we've been talking about
composing these sore
notes together and creating like a
minimax game or or an expecting max game
ana value function is we just do the
usual recurrence that we have been doing
in this class from the expected utility
to from the utility to come up with this
expected utility value for all the notes
that we have so there might be other
other scenarios that you might want to
think about for example for your
projects or like in general there are
other variations of games that you might
want to think about so what if like the
case that you're playing with multiple
opponents like so far we have talked
about like the two-player setting where
we have one opponent and one agent but
what if you have multiple opponents like
you can think about how the tree changes
in those settings or for example like
the taking turns aspects of it like is
it so if the game is simultaneous versus
your turn taking or like you can imagine
settings where you have some actions
that allow you to have an extra turn so
so you have two turns and then the next
person takes takes turn so you should
think about some of these some of them
come up into homework so think about
variations of games in general they're
kind of fun so to talk a little bit
about the computation aspects of this so
this is pretty bad are you talking about
a game tree which is similar to tree
search so we're taking its research
approach if you remember it's research
like the algorithms we're using like if
you have branching factor of B and some
depth of D then then in terms of time
it's exponential in the order of B to
the to D in this case so I'm using D for
the number of how do I say this so so
that's to D because the play the agent
plays and an opponent plays so that's
how I'm counting it so every every to D
like we have two replies but D that's
all right and then in terms of space its
order of D in terms of time it's
exponential that's pretty bad so for a
game of like chess for example the
branching factor is around thirty five
steps is around 50 so if you compute B
to the to D then it goes in the order of
like number of atoms and universe that
that's not doable we should we are not
able to use any of these methods so so
how do we make things faster so we
should be talking about high
things faster so there are two
approaches that we are talking about in
this class too to make things faster the
first approach is using an evaluation
function so using an evaluation function
what we can do is we can use
domain-specific knowledge about the game
to define almost like features about the
game in order to approximate like the
value did this value function at a
particular state so I'm gonna talk about
that a little bit and then another
approach is this approach which is kind
of simple and kind of nice which is
called alpha beta pruning and and alpha
beta pruning approach basically gets rid
of part of the tree if it realizes you
don't need to go down that tree that
part that part of the subtree so so it's
a pruning approach that doesn't explore
all of the tree only explores parts of
the tree so so we're going to talk about
both of them alright so evaluation
functions so let's talk about that okay
so the depths can be really like the
breadth and depth of the game can be
really large that's not that great so
one approach to go about solving the
problem is is to kind of limit the depth
so instead of like exploring everything
in a tree just limits the depth and get
to that particular depth and then after
that when you get to that depth just
call an evaluation function so so if you
were to like search the full tree this
was the recursion that that we had like
we have talked about right this is like
if you're doing a minimax approach this
is the recursion that you got to do you
got over all the states and actions and
go over all the tree but if you're using
a limited depth tree search approach
what you can do is you can basically
have this depth need and then decrement
D every time you go over an agent an
opponent like every time you go down the
tree and at some point D just becomes
zero so you get to put some particular
depth of the tree and when D becomes
zero you're going to call an evaluation
function on the states that you get okay
and this evaluation function is almost
of the same form of what future costs
maybe we're talking about search
problems right so so if you knew exactly
what it was that then you were done but
you don't know exactly what it is
because if you knew that you were to
solve like the whole tree search problem
but in general you can have some sort of
weak estimate of
of what what the future costs would be
so yeah so an evaluation function eval s
is a weak estimate of V minimax of s so
it's a weak estimate of your value
function okay all right so so analogy of
that is future cost in search problems
so how do we come up with an evaluation
function so we do it in a similar manner
to admitted in the learning lecture
where we're coming up with with features
and and and weights for those features
right so so if I'm playing like chess
and like the way we play it right like
we think about a set of actions that we
can take and where we end up at and and
based on where we end up at then we kind
of evaluate how good that were this
right we have some notions of features
and how good looking like how good that
boards would be from that point on and
that allows us evaluate what action to
pick right like when we play chess
that's kind of what we do we pick a
couple of actions and we see how the
boards would look like after taking them
an evaluation function kind of does the
same thing it tries to figure out what
are the things that we should care about
in a specific game in this case and in
chess and then try so I give values to
them so so it might be things like the
number of pieces we have or mobility of
those pieces or if our king is safe or
or if you have central control or not so
for example for the pieces what we can
do is we can look at the difference
between the number of pieces we have
between what we have and what our
opponent has so number of Kings that I
have versus number of opponents that I
have well that seems really important
because if I don't have a king an
opponent has a king then now I've lost
the game so so you might put like a
really large weight for that and you
might care about like the differences
between the number of ponds or number
Queens and other types of pieces that
you have on the board so so that allows
you to care about to think about how
good the board is or number of legal
moves that you have a number of legal
moves that your opponent has and then
that gives you some notion of like
mobility of that state ok all right
so so summary so far is yeah so this is
pretty bad order of B to the to D is
pretty bad and an evaluation function
basically tries to estimate this
the minimax using some domain knowledge
and then unlike a estar we actually
don't have like any guarantees in terms
of like error from from these sort of
approximations so but it's an
approximation people use it it's pretty
good we will talk about it a little bit
later next time when we think about like
what sort of weights we should we should
pick for each one of these for each one
of these features so you should think
learning when you think about what are
the weights we are using all right so
okay so now I want to spend a bit of
time on alpha beta pruning because this
is yeah important okay so alpha beta
pruning um yeah the concept of alpha
beta pruning is also pretty simple but I
think it's one of those things that was
it's kind of that table you should pay
attention to kind of get what it is
happening all right so so let's say that
you want to choose between some bucket a
and bucket be okay and you want to
choose the maximum value and then you
know that the values of a fall into like
three to five and the values of B fall
into five to ten so so they don't really
have like any any intersections between
each other so so in that case you don't
really care about your if you're picking
a maximum right you shouldn't care about
your bucket a or rest of your bucket a
because because you already know that
you're above wise you're happy with B
you shouldn't even look at a so so kind
of the underlying concept of alpha beta
pruning is is maintaining a lower bound
and upper bound on values and then if
the intervals don't overlap then
basically dropping part of the subtree
that you don't need to work on because
there is there is no overlap between
there okay so here's an example so let's
say we have these max notes and mid
notes and you're gonna go down and see
three and then this is a mid note so so
you're gonna get three here so when I
get to the max note here right I know
what I know is that the max node is
going to get three or higher right
that's one one thing that I would know
without even looking at anything on the
on the other side that I've been looking
at the sub tree on the Left I already
know that this max no it should get
three or higher right
your dad okay so so then when I go down
to the this min node and I see two here
right I know this is a min node it's
going to get a value that's less than or
equal to 2 less than or equal to 2 does
not have any interval with greater than
or equal to 3 so I should not worry
about that subtree did everyone see that
so maybe you're like let me draw that
here
so that's kind of like the whole concept
of what happens in the alpha-beta
pruning so I have this max node this was
three this was five I found that this
guy is three this is a max node whatever
it gets it's going to be greater than or
equal to three because it's already seen
three it's not gonna get any value less
than three all right so we know whatever
value we are gonna get at this max node
is going to be three or higher then I'm
gonna go down here and then I see two
here right
it's a min node whatever it gets is
going to be less than or equal to two so
less than or equal to 2 is the value
that's going to get popped up here I
already know less than or equal to 2 has
no interval with 3 or greater so I don't
even need to worry about this like I
like I can completely ignore this side
of the tree I don't need to know
whatever is happening down here I don't
even need to look at that okay cuz cuz I
like this value should be greater than
applause sorry
now minimum so it's a minimum it's a
minimum note right so it's going to be
your less than or equal it's a mid note
so I saw two if I see ten here or twenty
here like I'm not gonna pick that like
it's two or all right so yeah so if it
is 10 or 100 or whatever substrate is
there like we're not gonna look at that
so that that is kind of the whole
concept
all right so okay so the key idea of
alpha-beta pruning is as we're like an
optimal path is going to get to some
leaf node that has some utility and that
utility is the thing that is going to be
pushed up like like and then the
interesting thing is if you pick the
optimal path the value of the note on
that optimal path are all going to be
equal to each other like that basically
that utility that you're gonna get
pushed up all the way to the top so
because of that like we need to have
like these DS like we can't have
settings where we don't have any
intersections between the intervals
because we know if this rule is if this
were to be the optimal path the value on
this node should have been the same as
the value at this node the same as the
value at this node and and so on so if
they don't have any intervals then no
way that they would have the same value
and no way for that path to be the
optimal path okay so so that's kind of
the reason that it works cuz the optimal
path you're gonna have the same value
throughout okay
so all right so how do we actually do
this so the way we do this is we are
going to keep a lower bound on max nodes
so I'm gonna call that a s here so we
are gonna have a s which is a lower
bound on max nodes
so we're gonna keep track of that you're
also going to keep track of BS which is
an upper bound on mid notes and then if
they don't have any intervals we just
drop that subtree if they have intervals
we just keep updating a snps okay so so
here's an example so let's say that we
start with this top node somehow we have
found out that this top node should be
greater than or equal to 6 right somehow
I know it should be greater than or
equal to 6
okay so that is my a s value so my a s
is equal to 6 it is it is going to be a
lower bound on my max node I know that
the value the optimal value is going to
be something greater than equal to 6
ok then somehow we get to this min node
and then we realize that this min node
should be less than or equal to 8
so you're here let's say 8 is here
you still have some interval you're all
good right so the s is going to be equal
to 8 right we have an upper bound on the
min node and that tells us that upper
bound is 8 so the the value the optimal
value the value on the optimal path is
going to be less than or equal to 8 okay
so far so good then somehow I found out
that that one is greater than or equal
to 3 greater than or equal to 3 should
be fine right like greater than or equal
to 3 is still greater than or equal to 6
my a s in this case I'm gonna call this
s 1 s 2 s 3 is equal to 3 right cuz I
know I need to be greater than or equal
to 3 what like 6 already does the job
right like I don't need to worry about
that 3 so so that's all and then for
this last node I am at this min node and
I realize that ps4 I'm gonna call it B S
4 is equal to 5 and what this tells me
is that your value should be less than 5
and less than 5 so I'm going to update
less than 8 to less than 5
and now I don't have any inner walls so
what that tells me is that path is not
going to be the optimal path because
there is no interval so we're not going
to find this this one number that is
going to be the utility and what that
tells me is I can actually ignore that
whole subtree because because that's not
going to be in my optimal path I can I
can get rid of it I can ignore it yes so
we're ignoring three in a different way
so yeah so we're ignoring the value of
three because this is already encoded
here but we're ignoring the subtree of
five like I'm not exploring it like I
need to explore things after the three
already because I'd like like like with
the three of you already had an overlap
with the beta so you're looking at with
the B value you're looking at the
overlap between your upper bound of mid
node and lower bound of max node so that
interval is the interval you were making
sure it still has values in it if the
two or three instead we just ignore that
anyways because you have something else
that yeah yeah so yeah I think so yeah
so if you already have like if three
where two is that what you're saying
yeah so so you want to have non-trivial
intervals basically yes yes so like if
if you use the same value you still yeah
you don't have non-trivial intervals and
yeah what are we got six an a300 this is
an example that imagines some Holly
we'll talk about some examples where we
get them so let's talk about one more
example where we actually like it these
quotes for now just assume somehow we
have found this
I don't understand why brie is an
upper-bound what seems a lower bound so
um so then you actual value I'm not
showing a full example here so the
actual values are coming from somewhere
that I'm not talking about yet but oh
the one at the top okay oh sorry yeah so
the one at the top right so so this is a
min note let me note the same accent
right so at my mid note I found out that
minimum between three and five is three
right so max no it is maximizing between
three and a bunch of other things that's
that's what it's supposed to do right so
if it is maximizing between three and a
bunch of other things then it's at least
going to be three it's not going to be
two there's no way for it to be two or
it's not going to be zero right because
it's it's going to take maximum of three
and something else so that's why I'm
saying well this value whatever I'm
going to get at this max node it's going
to be greater than or equal to three X s
so now I come down here and I see like I
see this - this is a min note so the
value here is going to be the minimum
between two and whatever is down this
tree right so it is going to be at least
very bad way that we said it was it's
going to be it's going to be two or
lower so so what we're getting here is
going to be two or lower right so I'm
either going to get 2 or 1 or 0 or all
that and that's the value that's going
to be pushed up here right so that's the
value that's going to go down here it's
going to be a value that is 2 or lower
so if I'm maximizing between 3 and
something that is 2 or lower then 3 is
enough and I can kind of figure that out
based on these intervals and don't look
at this side of the tree like like once
I have I've seen this - I already feel
that there is no no trivial interval
between a value that's greater than 3
and a value that's less than 2 so I can
just not worry about stuff
all right so one quick cutter
implementation thing is we talked about
these ace a values and B values you can
keep track of only one value and that
would be this alpha value and beta value
where alpha value is just I'm gonna just
write it here
alpha value right so op of S is the max
of a s for all these s Prime's that are
listen s yeah so so it's so what this
basically says is it remember like when
we saw three we said well that's already
included like we already knew that
that's kind of the same idea so alpha s
is just going to be one value in this
case it's just going to be six because
like when I see three like I don't
really care about that three right like
I already know I'm greater than six
knowing that I'm greater than three is
not adding anything so we keep track of
one value off of Asaph of s in this case
F of s is just equal to six and a
similar thing for beta we are going to
keep track of beta of s and beta of s is
just minimum of BS s and then what I'm
writing here is just the ordering of the
notes that you have seen so so beta is s
fine and then you're looking at the
intervals like f of s and F of s and
above and beta of SM below and if those
intervals don't have any trivial
intersections then you can you can prune
part of the tree okay so this is more of
an implementation thing instead of
keeping track of all these assn BS s
just keep like one number one alpha and
1 beta okay all right
okay so let's look at one other example
so all right so I'm gonna just do this
example real quick okay so we're gonna
start from some top note we're gonna go
to this note this is a mid note between
nine and seven between nine and seven
right so it's a mid note I'm gonna get
this guy a seven I'm gonna realize that
this max node is going to be something
that's at least seven right it's going
to be something that's greater than or
equal to seven so my alpha
there's going to be seven right now I
know whatever value I'm gonna get is
going to be 7 or higher whatever value
to start notice going to get it's got to
be 7 or higher so now I come down here I
am at a mid note I see a 6 here
right I go here it's a min note so
whatever we get here is going to be less
than or equal to 6 right so it's going
to be 6 or something that is lower that
tells me my beta is is equal to 6 that
tells me whatever I'm getting in that
min node is going to be 6 and lower that
doesn't have any intersections with my
alpha of s so I can just not do anything
about this this branch like I don't need
to go over like all these other things
like I can kind of like ignore like this
whole bunch okay all right so now I go
back up I go down here I'm at a mid note
so remember the way we were computing
these beta values we were based on the
notice that we have seen previously so I
have a new beta now cuz I'm done with
this branch right so I need to get here
here I have a min between what is it 8 8
and 3 so okay so so I see my maybe let
me just rate I see my 8 here
it's a min node so it's going to be less
than or equal to 8 so my new beta value
is going to be 8 my alpha is still 7
because that's for my top note so it's 8
or lower we do have an interval
overlapping interval 7 to 8 everything
is good so I actually need to go and see
what this value is this value is 3 so I
get 3 here or like it's exactly equal to
3 so that updates my beta from 8 to 3
we'll have already explored that part of
the tree anyways but 3 you don't have an
interval if there were a bunch of things
below this 3 like I like a nice somehow
sound it's not like I wouldn't need to
explore it but we don't really have that
and then we just find that our optimal
value 7 so we just return something okay
and we did an explore this giant middle
of the tree okay one more slide and
enough two more two more quick one quick
idea okay so yeah alright so the order
of things actually matters so the only
thing I want to mention about this idea
of pruning is this order of things
matter so so when you look at this
example remember we didn't explore
anything about the ten because we
already knew that this value needs to be
greater than equal to three these are my
buckets right if I swap the buckets like
if I just swap the order of buckets I
moved the to ten bucket to this side
three five pocket to the other side I
wouldn't be able to do that I actually
need to explore the whole tree because
my alpha and beta
wouldn't have the same properties so the
order that you're putting things on the
tree actually matters and you should
care about that so worst case scenario
our ordering is terrible so we need to
actually go over the full tree that's
order of B to the to D that's the worst
case scenario
there are ends of this best ordering
where you don't explore like half of it
so you can't like if you had that if you
if you have a tree where you're you can
explore up to like depth ten then with
the best order and you can actually
explore up to depth like 20 so sorry
that's a huge improvement actually so
best ordering is going to be order of B
to the D and then random ordering turns
out to be pretty okay to so random
ordering would be order of P to the 2
times 3/4 times D so even if you had a
random ordering it would be better than
the worst-case scenario and then well
how do you figure out what is a good
bordering in ordering well we can have
this evaluation function remember you're
computing the evaluation function and
and what you can do is you can order
your Super Max nodes you can order the
successors by decreasing evaluation
function and then for min nodes you can
order successors by increasing
evaluation functions that allows you to
prune as much things as possible all
right so with that I'll see you guys
next lecture talking about tea new
learning